all right Raymond I know you have an
update on that story that you brought us
last night on the hotels in Manhattan
being transformed into these migrant
centers what's the latest Laura scenes
like this have greeted New York
commuters outside the Roosevelt Hotel
which have been transformed into
shelters for illegal migrants I spoke
with local business owners and those who
work in the area what have you seen
being this close I mean your store
literally backs up to the Roosevelt
Hotel what have you witnessed is is
really horrible horrible with children
kids babies mothers fathers sitting on
the floor they don't know what they are
doing it's not even even affecting just
just this business it's affecting all
the businesses around this area what do
you think of the city spending 225
million dollars to house these migrants
here first of all that's a crazy number
I mean City needs those money elsewhere
No Doubt uh why is why does New York owe
this to the rest of the United States
for this to pay that bill that I don't
know this should definitely be dealt
differently I'm gonna tell you what I
feel about this we have homeless vets
here in this city and state and we're
not even taking care of our own people I
believe I believe in helping everybody
but how do we go about helping other
people but we're not even taking care of
there's a homeless vet that used to
sleep in there he can no longer sleep in
his doorway because now that it's taken
by the migrants it's just it's it's a
travesty and shame shame shame on Eric
Adams have you heard about the pilot
program that they're offering to people
in which they're going to offer them
five different states to live out of
give them a stipend to live for a year
and give them work and I got this from a
friend of mine who was a counselor here
in the Hotel this is not the solution we
have to do something about the Border
let's face it Laura the city of New York
has already spent five billion dollars
to care for the hundred thousand plus
migrants and more are coming and we
don't know who they are yeah we have
seven what seven and a half million
people and Counting and on and then
gotaways yeah there are public schools
and our ESL programs are completely
overloaded we don't have enough teachers
for the American kids and and it's it's
ridiculous Health Care all the rest
people underestimate the danger of this
Laura ice just arrested 366 illegal
people with criminal records and 75
000 illegals have now been named
National Security threats by border
patrol the worst is yet to come and as
long as we're talking about scary things
for Joe Biden and all the world these
could be the most frightening words ever
uttered the word of the day is
understand divine's gonna be fine but
let us also understand that every vice
president
every vice president
understands that when they take the oath
that they must be very clear about the
responsibility they may have
to take over the job of being president
I am no different
why don't I feel reassured Laura you
hear that that's like verbal Ex-Lax
everybody runs to the toilets when they
hear that but this conversation of
Kamala Harris's president in Waiting is
becoming more urgent because we have a
president now giving quickie speeches
and when he does host an event like at
yesterday's medal ceremony he just
wanders out in the middle of the
proceedings
thank you
Lord look look at the faces of the
photographer and one of the attendees
they're like where the hell is he going
should I leave I don't know what to do
here it's it's amazing it's amazing he
gets away with this it looks like that
Medal of Honor recipient was almost
relieved when Biden left the stage i i s
I sensed a feeling of relief coming over
him yet the White House spokesman claims
this was all planned the quick getaway
he left as planned as it was planned he
left when there was a pause in the
program in order to minimize to minimize
his close contact with attendees
Laura
dog that ate Secret Service agents did
not have close contact with people but
Biden is in close contact he shouldn't
have come to the event if he's in
doesn't want to pay close contact he's
hanging he's hanging the metal around
the recipient's neck I mean as an elder
two elderly uh gentleman this man's an
American hero and he has to have him
breathing on him I don't care if he
tested positive or not are we doing
contact tracing still we I'm sure
there's a lot of contact tracing that we
should be doing providing God this is
the nightmare at least he found the exit
Laura that's a plus I'll give him that
that is progress and we'll take it where
we can get it right man thank you great
to see you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else